osmosis you're watching osmosis this is
why osmosis scales more than any
tactical corporate movement
and build businesses
you know when I think about
a company off-site a retreat of leaders
I really think of them as watershed
moments in the year of a company I think
of them as the biggest single
opportunity to get a bunch of people
aligned on a mission I think about them
as an opportunity to be vulnerable as an
opportunity to be strategic I think of
them as an opportunity to bring the
family back together and really talk
about the things that matter at the most
macro everybody
everybody everybody is caught in the
day-to-day the meetings the grind then
you get caught up into the micro and
minutia the the meetings the scheduling
the stuff that really isn't driving the
role of a business and so for me what's
really exciting about getting these
together sessions is like really sitting
down and getting a bunch of leaders to
really think about what are we doing
here the why the and talking about the
two to three to four to five to seven
real issues that we're struggling with
that as a team we're not making happen
when I get vaynerx together it's a real
opportunity occasionally I like to do
them in the summer where you can just
sit outside shoot the [__] as you're
watching this as you see the Zack
nallers who runs Vayner speakers or Lisa
Buckley's who run you know LA or SID
there sitting next to jamo we really
talked a lot about like how to use me in
my business I'm a unique X Factor right
um I'm not a figurehead a lot of you who
are watching this right now don't even
realize that I'm the actual day-to-day
operating CEO of the company that if you
looked at my calendar you wouldn't even
understand what's going on because a lot
of you view me as a personality or an
influencer or a public figure but
literally I'm spending 13 hours a day
running businesses actually for real
we've just figured out how to create
content in a different way and so what's
happening here is we're really in the
trenches and so a lot of this
conversation that you're watching is
people are thinking and pondering is
them understanding things we talked
about which was for example what if you
had to be out for eight weeks because of
a personal matter are your direct
reports capable of making it happen and
when I looked around and saw 40 faces
collectively say oh [__] I knew that
people have not been building up their
people good enough or are not managing
up or don't have the right Talent
underneath them that's organizationally
important an off-site like this got me
to get a collective understanding of
where do my leaders sit with their
leaders there's some head shaking going
on and so these are the things a leader
has to do and this is what I tend to do
and off-site's here but not to mention
the best part the Serendipity of all
these people it makes it more human for
all of them they become more human with
each other and become closer after this
and then at the end of the day just like
we talk about a lot once you're able to
take strangers to acquaintances
acquaintances to friends and then
finally friends to family you'll achieve
everything you're trying to do
foreign
[Music]